hey everybody chuck nice here and i just
want to let you know that we have a 2022
survey that i need you to fill out it's
going to help us get to know you a
little better it's going to improve our
content and it will help us pick the
right advertisers that'll keep us going
in 2022 and beyond it only take about 10
minutes for you to fill out
and one of you will be chosen to receive
a cosmic queries book signed by the man
himself dr neil degrasse tyson you can
find the survey at our website
starttalkradio.net
go ahead fill it out you won't be sorry
[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
and if it's going to be cosmic aquarius
we're probably going to have chuck nice
in the house yes
chuck nice your personal nothing
personally i'm your personal
you're the uh you're the personal
astrophysicist making yourself available
for people
all across the cosmos i am your personal
nothing
lord
are you are you a lord chuck here we go
lord nice julie
duly designated by
a general in the u.s air force all right
lord lord nice you got questions this is
the beginning of the year you know a
third near the pandemic so
a lot of people are bummed out
but you know how how much longer must we
endure
but a new year of course is always a
time for sort of thinking fresh thoughts
and possibly
putting a positive spin on bad things
and just putting positive out there
at all
whether or not it's a spin on something
bad so
so maybe i'll try to give positively
tinted answers to every question you
have
because it's otherwise just a grab bag
right
let's be real though i mean when do you
ever give a truly negative answer well
that's true dr tyson i would like to
know about time deadly dilation uh well
dumbass
uh
it's like you you're never negative
no that's true no i'm not negative
that's true that's true but maybe i can
do a little extra we'll see we're gonna
like that this this is the time of year
to do that so you're absolutely right
okay hey how about sean grossman let's
uh let's see what sean grossman is
saying here doesn't say where he's from
but he says uh hey there dr tyson
uh what do you think our first contact
with alien life will be
and how will it be
received and i i think by received he
means like how will it come to us not
how will we respond to it
okay so i have to stay positive here
right off the bat it's a challenge
first question first question is
challenging the possibility
we always would ask us what does he
prefer to be boiled or sauteed exactly
yeah it's like happy new year what 1202.
well there goes the positivity
wow so
i
i think i've said this before but let me
say it with precision
in this moment
i think the evil alien
trope which is in so many so i think i
think all of them except for e.t maybe
all right i don't know uh right they're
always evil and they want to harm us
and
and that is not derived from
you know it's it's
it's what we
think aliens will do to us so we're
projecting that onto aliens
well yeah we think there's one but it
can't be based on that because we don't
know anything about the aliens but what
we do know
is ourselves
and i think
those scenarios
are based on not what we think aliens
would do to us but what based on what we
know we would do to ourselves
because we've already done it
the issue is you have a high technology
civilization
encountering a low technology
civilization and it has never boded well
for the low technology civilization
among humans
so i think these are projections these
are mirrors to our own conduct without
us even knowing it
so let me take a different tact and say
maybe the aliens are better than us
maybe they
they have no reason to be evil or to
take our resources here on earth because
the universe is full of resources
there's nothing special that earth
offers that they can't get elsewhere so
they can't be looking for that
and and so maybe they just want to make
friends
with us
and just you know break out the m m's
break out the m m's and the reese's
piece
we're gonna make some alien friends
give them a sugar dependence yeah they
have diabetes all right
well
now but what about this
just to dovetail into the question
what if the aliens are so advanced that
what we perceive to be evil
they perceive to just be the fact that
we're insignificant
so or not perceived let me say what we
perceive to be evil
is this your question no no this is this
is you know kind of an extension of of
the mr grossman's question
um
i am lying this is my question
you're the lion hey look i got to sleep
when i can
no that no that's a good one we'll take
it as a as a as a car as a as an add-on
customer's question right the patreon
comment the patreon agent
could if you're walking down the street
and you step on a worm right you don't
want all the worms thinking your evil
person who hates worms it was just kind
of inadvertent right yeah i mean worms
mean nothing's true
yeah so so but then why would they spend
all that effort to come to earth see i
think that's we're allowed to ask that
question because if they are
it's like because you're not going to
say let me drive a thousand miles and
then step on worms
in the lawn of a stranger this is not
this
so
that's that's funny
that's pretty funny where you going
arizona why gotta kill a scorpion
i gotta kill a scorpion you're driving
to arizona to step on a scorpion
it's by accident yeah okay yeah exactly
right yeah okay
so so
so that's a good point
but
uh yeah i don't see them coming this far
for that reason
right
and
yeah yeah so so maybe they just want to
you know make be friends with us right
that's all okay yeah exactly that's
that's true okay i like that and once i
think about it and guess what you did it
you stayed positive
everything okay one other positive thing
i have a negative positive thing ready
okay
if the alien says
take me to your leader
right
them to a scientist anywhere
don't take them right whatever you do
don't don't take them to the head of any
country right or any
no no this is a bias i have it
it's just
i don't want a politician to be the
first encounter with an alien i kind of
don't want that
because politicians can't get along with
each other right
how we think we they get along within
ailings whereas
scientists get along with each other
internationally and have done so ever
since there's been science
so if there's a chance
of of of kind
uh considerate exchanges
that might have some way to even
communicate
all right they're not going to be
speaking english or mandarin or spanish
or swahili or urdu no they're speaking
none of that
they speak they might have a periodic
table
they might have a periodic table of
elements that you can compare it with or
pythagorean theorem there'll be some
rudiments of
cosmically common
communication
okay
that we might be able to invoke
are you the first ones to say hi
you can also take them to oprah
um
clearly that works
i don't know why the more sci-fi movies
don't do that where they land and they
go take us down we're down with
everybody right right exactly you know
all right let's go to this open down
with everybody uh this is skyletta
ramona um sky letter ramona uh hello
uh dr tyson i'm sure that is not what
she calls it
i'm
something tells me that's not how it's
pronounced but go i'm sure it's not but
you know but she she'll figure it out
[Laughter]
what kind of
you figured out you know who the hell
this is
like if i was on this if i put a
question into this show and they said we
got buck rice from new jersey i'd be
like hey
that's probably me
chuck messed it up that's probably me
all right this is a sky letter from
hawaii she says hello dr tyson and lord
nice uh do you believe
that particles
are point like in particles or string
like
as in string theory also i heard from
brian greene that string theory required
10 dimensions for the math of string
theory to work is that so and why that's
a lot that's a lot in that question
skyler that's a lot god man that's the
rest of the distract you in hawaii
i know you've been surfing
be out on the church shore right now
just chilling
sucking on a
coconut drink and
watching a sunset
you're talking about string theory in 10
dimensions
[Laughter]
good stuff good stuff i mean that's the
rest of the show to be honest but you
know okay so here's the thing uh of all
the particles
have a known
size
except electrons
electrons have no known size
they are smaller than our
greatest efforts to ever measure how
small they are oh my god so as far as
we're concerned they're
infinitesimally small
infinitesimally small how is it that i
did not know this all this time we have
been together that is a fascinating
question i did not yes there's no
there's no known dimension for electrons
correct get out correct
correct plus plus while we're there
every electron is identical to every
other electron
so
if i have a wire
filled with electrons
okay
and i stick one electron in the back of
where i am and this wire goes i'm in a
new york and you're in la i put a wat i
put an electron in the back that one the
the negative charge will push the other
one forward and it'll keep doing that
until an electron pops out the other
side and as far as that person is
concerned i sent them my electron
amazing that's really cool even though
my electron is still back here oh my god
i just like the distinction is not
that's awesome that's why electricity
works right that's why i can send you a
message you get it instantly it all goes
by electrons over wires and all the
electrons are identical and i put
something here it pops out the other
side and there you have it did the
electron actually go from new york to la
no
wow
yeah that that's great so chuck i didn't
finish answering the question but we got
to take a quick break but when we come
back
we will talk about how and why and where
electrons
are strings
may be strings
star talk continues
we're back cosmic queries beginning of
the year edition
trying to spend positive thoughts until
all that has brought us down in these
past two years entering our third year
in the coronaverse
and then knocking out the greek alphabet
there
omicron dude well when we get to omega
uh chris you're back nevermind sorry
that is the end of it all
i was about
no letters left
i was like well
i was about to say kiss your black
behind goodbye but
i was like let me chill out
yeah but when we yeah omega that's it
that's it when you get to omega
the greek letters the greek alphabet
can't help you that's it game over baby
game is over
i'm pretty sure covert 19
doesn't know about how many greek
letters there are in the alphabet yeah i
don't think it cares about that no i'll
take a career
um
i left off with a question from someone
who should be distracted by other things
in hawaii what what's this person's name
uh yeah that's skyeletta
who
skyoleta last name uh ramona
scott skye skyletta ramona writing from
hawaii right distracted by
string theory
clearly it's another crappy day in
paradise
okay
so back to string theory
so we have several fundamental particles
electrons are among them quarks
uh uh photons the antimatter counterpart
to an electron is a positron okay so so
oh so what string theory suggests
is
all particles are strings
that vibrate differently
from each other
so electron looks different from a quark
or from anything else because of the
nature of the vibrating string
because of how the string is vibrating
but it would mean everything is just
made of strings right so that simplifies
it
we're not made of multiple different
particles we made of one kind of string
vibrating differently now
the point is
that exists in a higher dimension but as
that string
as we experience that string in our
lower dimensions
those vibrations manifest as these
particles
so it's not like is the particle just a
point
or is it a string
the whole point of the string the whole
the whole feature of the string i like
is that it is a string in higher
dimensions and a particle in your
dimensions
that's awesome i like i like the idea of
the whole point of the string
anyway uh
that's uh okay cool well great uh great
great question skyletto all right that
is give me more here we go here we go
here we go um
let's go with ed edward trahan and
edward says hello neil hello chuck my
question is if humans were to build a
massive object in space let's say just
the size of the moon would it generate a
gravitational pull if so would it depend
on what materials would it be made of
and what shape it was or is there a
certain size threshold uh what is it
that would give it gravitational pull i
love that great question so first of all
you're gonna make something the size of
the moon you need that much mass
kind of okay so where are you gonna get
it from so what you could do is get it
all from the moon
and then our moon would disappear and
then you just create another moon so
what did you gain by that right
is actually
uh is about one percent of the mass of
the earth
so if you wanted to hew forth
another one percent of earth's mass and
put it up there in orbit you cart it out
there yeah just put it out there and
just keep adding to it and you can just
keep building and building and building
and we can watch this moon construction
project in orbit around the earth
and yes
the the gravitational field depends on
only two things
how much mass it has
and how far away you are from it and
that will tell you how strong the
gravity will be at your location
but for this for the for your gravity on
the surface it depends what the density
of the material is that you use
so the moon
density
earth is a combination of rock density
and metal density because we have a
metal core the moon doesn't have a metal
core so depending how dense the material
is but yeah you can build up stuff and
create a whole world and yes it will
have its own gravity and and you want to
build a shape
that's not a sphere that's very hard to
do above a certain size
because the gravity will make the high
places low and
and and fill in the low places and make
them high so that's why large objects
are all spherical um in the universe
large sort of solid objects so yay yeah
you can't make a cube this is the moon
it won't it won't maintain itself in
that shape
i don't know if you knew that cool
yeah if you're small enough it'll take
on any shade if it's smaller that's why
if you look at tiny asteroids they look
like idaho potatoes they're not spheres
right they can be all kinds of weird
funky shapes
because above a certain size
gravity becomes more important
than the things that are otherwise
giving shape to it
and gravity wants all parts of that
object to come as close to the center as
possible
and if you're high up and there's a
ditch near you it's going to take stuff
that was high up and put it down in the
ditch
to bring it closer to the center of the
object
compared to the 8 000 miles of earth's
diameter
5 miles on 8 000
so earth is basically perfectly smooth
if you're a giant and you came up to it
with a finger and rubbed your rubbed
your finger across you would not notice
the mountains the valleys the lakes the
oceans
and in fact if you shrunk earth down to
the size of a cue ball
it would be smoother than all cue balls
ever made
to say nice
okay
oh
well that's that's a very interesting
game of billiards that's all i can say
yes so you're gonna so you're gonna make
a moon
if it's big it's gonna be spherical
deal with it there you go
that's very cool all right everybody i
know we are getting tight here we go
this is brandon
and um but let me say well i'm supposed
to say nice things for the new year i'm
supposed to say nice thing for new year
for every question so if you want two
moons that would be doubly romantic
how do you like that
all right
yeah that'd be beautiful very good
over here you'd have a crescent moon and
over there you'd have a half moon
and
uh that would just be that that'd be bad
it would be
sweetie let's take a walk by the
moonlight you know it's there's always
moonlight okay always
not doing anything special there's
always been like
this is brandon he says hey neil i have
been a fan for years you actually helped
me get interested in space along with
your book the universe in a nutshell my
question for you is
why do you think there is so much
skepticism and belief about the moon
landing scientifically there's more
evidence to support that we went than
there is to say that we didn't yet there
are still naysayers and skeptics with
all the footage audio documents etc do
you think there's any believable way
they could have faked it
oh man okay so first of all i i think
there is a book called the universe in a
nutshell but i didn't write it okay
okay
so
just put that out there if we're talking
about truth in advertising
wow if we're talking about what people
believe and what they don't believe uh i
think that actually is such a book i
didn't write it um the the book you
might be referring to is
um
um what's it called astrophysics for
people in a hurry that could be the book
yes that you're thinking that's what
he's talking about but uh so my take on
the on the moon landing and we got to
end on this question because we're okay
i take too long to answer all so my take
on the moon landing is
how amazing it is that we live in a time
where our science and technology is so
advanced
that people living among it
remain in denial
of what those advances can bring to us
for me it's evidence of how advanced we
are
what a compliment
that's how i
i mean it relates to arc arthur c
clarke's edict
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
right so if you don't know or understand
how advanced these technologies are
it will look like magic to you
and you're not going to believe that
magic is real so you'll have to say it's
faked because you know hollywood is
really good at faking this stuff
again these are very high compliments
for the technologies that we have
so plus
we went we went to the moon
nine times
so if you think we faked it you'd have
to think we faked it nine times okay
right
right and people know that only happens
in marriage
no
chuck
this is the new year chuck say nice
things
nice things nice things
so
um so yeah i so it's i've stopped
chasing down the people who are
technology deniers
because i know what the technology is i
know how we make it happen yeah it costs
a lot of money we spent a lot of money
um and by the way you can calculate how
much fuel is in that saturn v rocket
when it launched
if you do that you add this is enough
fuel to take the lunar module the three
astronauts uh into orbit leave orbit go
to the moon orbit the moon return to the
orbit come back and land that's how much
fuel is in there so
where the hell did they think that thing
was going you saw it at launch that was
real
what do you think was going to piggly
wiggly to pick up some groceries no that
sucker was leaving earth
so if you do the math
you end up less stupefied by the things
the math empowers in modern society
that's all
this is cosmic queries uh 2022
yeah yeah let's um
let's jump into
jmaxx47
and jmx is my real name is jason m
benton jason m from bentonville arizona
and he says hello dr tyson
please remind us of
plans to return to the moon
or plans for moon habitation
or maybe a moon space station
are those things
relevant
relevant mm-hmm
that's yeah that's a loaded question
like relevant to what well into the
future to itself
to
see we know what's good about the moon
as a target even though we've been there
before
right i'm sure we'd all get excited if
we landed there again and we would be
really irritated if somebody else lands
there again before we do right
but i can tell you this that the moon
you can get there in three days that's
that's a news cycle right right right
you can launch today
get there by friday or whatever whatever
get there within the week you can track
it you can do do your business on the
moon and then come back and all that
happens over a time period where no one
loses interest
in your journey
so i don't mean to speak of it on such
crass terms but the reality is public
support is fed by media interest and if
the media can stay attached to what's
going on over that appropriate time
interval i think it's a win-win for
everybody
so trips back to the moon with human
beings yeah i mean they're in nasa sites
i i always
think they um the timelines are a little
uh more optimistic than what is real but
who am i to say all right uh but uh the
artemis mission is is is a is a
architecture of rockets and capsules
that'll take human beings back to the
moon and i don't see why that won't just
continue uh within the nasa budget
that's already been allocated so yeah
now what was the last part what is its
value
um
yeah well space stations on the moon
moon habitation
would those things hold value are they
relevant in any way are they relevant
well if people are interested they're
relevant if you're not interested it's
not relevant to you by the way a whole
lot goes on in the world that you might
not be interested in that doesn't mean
it shouldn't happen because it actually
interests other people right so
so i don't have a problem with that and
at some point you'd want to attach to
private enterprise there could be some
interesting
journeys uh you know
would there be you know disneyland on
the moon that'd be weird and initially a
little sad but then you say
yeah of course that's what it's going to
be all right
so is there anything is there any
resource on the moon
i remember once um just give me a second
here i don't want to screw it up you
said that the moon is bombarded all the
time with
helium three
yeah and yeah and once again you have
not earned the right to ask a question
even though you're my co-host
but i will address this and i'll
dovetail it into the actual patreon
member's question okay okay
so in the solar wind
these particles that this effluence from
the sun that leaves the sun
continuously
because the sun is losing mass
continuously to these outer particles
the solar wind and we call it the solar
wind it's pretty accurate to call it
that actually nice because they're
particles that come from you can't see
them they're small they're fast moving
these are the particles that hit earth's
atmosphere
and render it aglow and you get the
aurora
and you get especially good aurora when
it when you get solar flares
aimed at earth because then it's it's
intensified so some of these particles
are
helium the helium nucleus minus
one of the neutrons
so a red bloody helium nucleus has two
protons two neutrons but you take away
so that's helium four because they're
four particles take away one of them you
get helium three okay
so what bfd the point is if you
if you harvest
the helium-3 which is embedded in the
the soils of the moon it's not really
soil it's called regalith it's like
pulverized rock
soil on earth has like microbes and
things and that's what we mean by soil
there's none of that is on the moon but
but i i loosely call it soil it's
embedded in the soils of the moon if you
remove that you can put that into it a
nuclear fusion reactor
and helium-3 is one of the intermediate
steps of going from hydrogen to full up
helium-4 and if you supply it with that
oh my gosh it's a game changer for your
thermonuclear fusion reactors in terms
of the cost benefit calculation you'd be
doing for it so i i'd be disappointed if
we had colonies on the moon that didn't
undergo a nuclear fusion as their energy
source to power the entire moon because
it's free sitting right there on the in
this in the soil oh that's okay that's
very cool that's there it is so there
you have it man that that you did tie in
good memory check good memory chuck yeah
yeah
uh yeah i was uh throwing a dart at a
board but it actually okay no i'm joking
uh by the way and one thing about
colonies yeah you know if if there's
disneyland and there's you know there
have hotels and and restaurants and you
know you know parades whatever i mean
why not i mean i don't have to see any
problem with that and
i don't know about that it's kind of i
don't know i feel like we're somehow
sullying the moon like our presence you
know how big the universe is
i feel like we sell you the universe to
be honest
it's like
by the way here's one something for you
ready on the moon helium blue balloons
oh wow yeah there's a little thing they
only rise up because they're more
buoyant than the air that surrounds them
if you go to the vacuum of the moon your
healing boom will fall as fast as a
brick will that's great on the moon
that's your helium balloon
yeah yeah i tell you that i think we
sully the universe that i have uh
i have a thought where
in every uh sci-fi movie there's a a
planet that's destroyed and then
whoever's watching becomes the last
of that species and it's just like i
watched my planet destroyed right and
i'm like you know
if it were earth
and i'd be like chuck man you just saw
your planet destroyed and be like
yeah
i mean
you got to know those people
maybe it's not that bad of a sheep
chuck
you just have happy thoughts at the
beginning of 2022. uh that's true
exactly i've got a happy thought for you
i got one ready so um this is an old
oldie but goodie but i got to say it
right so
um you know the the if you do have a
whole colony you'd have all the
trappings of what you'd have on earth
except on the moon and but you'd have to
all that if you go to the restaurants
the food would be very different because
you're in
less gravity and less air pressure and
so
so uh
if you want to sort of know about those
restaurants however different the food
will be what you know is they won't have
any atmosphere at all
okay
that's stupid but it's it's fun okay
what else all right tim just a couple
more questions okay go tim jackson says
this
uh with
with the ever increasing
commercialization of space how is nasa
positioned
in the role of the space community
uh and how is it changing
what are some of the upcoming missions
that may
um
partner commercial enterprise along with
the missions of nasa let's set the
record straight nasa has always
partnered with commercial industries
right the lamb
that landed on the moon yes was designed
and built at grumman aerospace right
here in bethpage long island all right
i'm speaking to you from new york city
you go to beth page today people still
walk the streets proud that they had an
uncle an aunt somebody who worked for
that lamb
all right and so it was partnered so we
paid for it grumman built it okay so we
partnered with with private enterprise
from the beginning the difference is
they
we had specs
that they had to be built to and so
grumman is sort of responding to nasa in
these in these uh
in what it produces
that's
different from what spacex doing spacex
says i'm building a building a rocket
whether you like it or not oh i have a
rocket and i can launch satellites and
nasa says hey you could do it on the
cheap and we got to launch this
satellite
we want to buy your payload for that
next launch
so it's still a commercial partner the
difference is nasa's getting it off the
shelf rather than a one-off which is
what the lambs were they were just
one-offs for those missions so so the
partnership has always been there okay
and the united space alliance and it's
gone through several different
incarnations with names but boeing has
been a part of that lockheed martin
lockheed later lockheed martin has been
a part of that um from martin marietta
but before they merged so there's a long
history of this this is so here's the
difference you need nasa to do the
frontier stuff that doesn't yet have a
profit motive that does it has
geopolitical value
but nobody can make the money on it just
yet
because there's a risk factor they don't
know about and where and what do they do
and why and how would they
the governments do it we find out where
the where it's safe to land where it's
not all that gets figured out
private industry comes in afterwards so
that's why we now private industry
taking people into orbit it used to be
just nasa
and now the spacex taken astronauts to
the space station let's do it that way
because if you're private enterprise you
could probably do it for less
but we don't but nasa doesn't have
spacex doing a frontier mission
on mars if it's a one-off that's not a
business model
and all research typically are one-offs
the the james webb space telescope
that's not on somebody's shelf
right that stuff got built from from
scratch
okay
and so that's what you need nasa for
that the frontier the rest of that
private enterprise brings up the rear
and that's how it ha that's how it was
uh um
with the early ages of exploration where
governments sent the explorers and then
later on the dutch east india trading
company made a buck off of it that's
right yeah yeah oh so there you have it
private private public partnerships hand
in hand yeah yeah that's right
always always yeah yeah always that's
how as it can be as it has been as it
should be
okay so chuck we hardly have any time
left let me this is the beginning of the
year
can i offer you just some personal
reflections always yes always okay i
might miss your personal reflections
because we used to do it all the time
when we uh when we did uh your cosmic
perspective cosmic perspective we
stopped doing your cosmetics we stopped
this okay let me know why let me hand
you one right now okay okay
we've been through some very challenging
years yes with the uh corona virus the
covid 19 virus and i was early out of
the box on that one with a tweet on
march 6 2020. i said this is a virus
that doesn't care where you live who you
pray to you know who you have sex with
uh none of that it doesn't care about
any of that it just cares that you're a
human
and so to combat this we need
coordination internationally across
tribal boundaries as we've all been
expressing them in modern times to fight
a common enemy it's almost like an
invader from space it's not from space
but it's like that the aliens just want
to kill all the humans we have to band
together and we didn't
and that upsets me as a member of a
species that has the power and the
knowledge to have done something about
it
so for this year the 2022
i i want to believe
that
people will see and understand and
recognize what value science has
not only to our ability to thrive but at
its most base level our ability to
survive
we science tells us what's around the
corner and why and how dangerous it is
and what we can and should be doing and
you know what space exploration does for
me when i see the nasa docket for 2022 i
say yes oh we're going to try to deflect
an asteroid and save humanity in in in
doing so oh we're going to go back to
mars a neighboring planet we're going to
we're going to do these things and and
it's a reminder how great we are as a
species how great we are as an intellect
and so so what a shame to have this
intellect and not invoke it in the best
ways we know how
so i look forward to 2022 as a way where
humans
are back on the map
showing the universe how smart we are
so that we become better shepherds of
our own fate
as we move forward
in this
century
like this millennium
that's a cosmic perspective
chuck
thanks for being here and that's uh
that's beautiful man that's i mean that
really i'm just screaming at you here
i'm just feeling no you're not it's it's
a no well you know when you're when
you're
um
when you raise your voice
to
in in a positive tone it's not screaming
it's just it's it's excitement it's not
screaming i'm sorry about that yes yeah
you know if you were saying chuck go to
hell that'd be scary
that would have been screened
[Laughter]
all right all right we gotta call it
quits there uh happy 2022 to everyone um
star talk is still strong um we're we're
at it and we've got more
of the universe to bring down to earth
uh much more of it
coming soon
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always and forever and
for this year and forevermore
keep looking up
[Music]